pewdiepie
i'm back baby back in minecraft how long
has it been
seriously four months four months
jesus christ well before we begin
you might be wondering why i wear
mysterious mask
well watch to end the video to find out
let's go
i cannot wait any further
[Music]
yeah it's me here you must be starving
chicken
no you don't want my chicken uh
wait what did they change the controls
or something i can't click on him
oh there we go why is there an egg here
sven
wait wait a minute ah
i'm not here wait i'm playing on
minecraft my uh
my sis account what the hell are you
serious sven you wouldn't interact with
marzia
this means sven is not the same after
all
i never been so proud of you sven good
job good boy
he's loyal even after four months of a
loneliness
a hot minecraft girl comes near him he
doesn't even move
that's a goddamn legend what an absolute
savage
i've never been this proud all right
marzia look out
okay okay it works it works wait what is
this
what the hell is that what happened sven
know what happened to my
skin face what's that what happened in
my face
why my penis wait
no no better look at me
don't look at me why
why oh my god dude oh he won't even look
at me
then come back love me i love you
i love you i love you don't you
recognize your father
who did this how did this happen legit
did someone hack my minecraft account
is that even oh no someone hacked my
minecraft account
i have like the shittiest password on
this one i got i gotta change
password hold up god damn it oh my god
no
no no
no you changed
all right that's just uncalled for man
you can change my skin but don't change
my name buff
god damn it why would someone do this
and then not change the password
hold up i'm gonna change back god
[ __ ] damn it sven
i just wanted to come back and play
minecraft is that too much to ask
let me play a minecraft i guess we've
been playing minecraft realms actually
now i think about it we have played some
minecraft
okay stupid packers come and hack me
all right am i back to normal yes ah
look i got a swedish cape now sven
sen it's me i know i have a different
name in the wait where they go
there you are there there it's me love
me
love me here chicken yeah you love me
all right
so i want to keep oh god i forgot oh god
damn it's so annoying
i don't know how you got here i want to
murder you but i made a promise
and i'm making it now i made a promise
to myself but i'm making it now
i'm not going to kill anyone from now on
no one dies there's been too many deaths
in this minecraft playthrough
from now on none of my pets will die
okay if any one of my pets dies
i will quit minecraft forever isn't that
right jurgen
you're good i love you i love you
yeah who the hell are you deep steep
deep uh sure of course how can i forget
the
uh sven cat yes sven cat yes thank you
sorry sorry sorry jesus christ ah my
best friend
uh crying panda and uh um
sven don't try and protect them oh
jacksepticeye ikea bird
yes the whole gang is here all right so
what i want to do next
in minecraft is something that i haven't
done in a very long
time i mean i've never done it which is
killing the ender dragon
apparently you can re-summon the ender
dragon if you
get uh er eye of ender which should be
easy to get
uh and you get the i think it's called
an end crystal
yeah yeah that's it if you get four of
these you can resume
the ender dragon i thought yeah that's
it that's right so you need i need a gas
tier and i need island there which
should be easy i think i already have
ion there
so we're going back in the nether sven
there surrender
where is sven oh my god i forgot to say
hi to la brita
do not move do not move in a billion
years
because you will die don't move
do not move
i got you i will save you oh god oh god
yeah i saved your life
be quiet oh god i forgot how annoying
they are
shut up [ __ ] all right
keep guarding them jesus christ dude
it's good to be back
not gonna lie it's been spent
stay here stay here with us i have to go
and get here
i'm going in boy as always we have to
pay the poll
sweet home alabama poll alabama
[ __ ] are you alabama i sacrificed
three eggs thank you please
please let me walk on your land
this is perfect i actually need to kill
one of these oh god
careful alabama careful
no yes did he drop one did he drop one
i need his tears everyone get away get
away go go go go go go get away
i need his tears i salvaged tears did
you get it did you steal the tears
huh was it you oh god oh god what have i
done
i made a mistake i'm sorry i made a
mistake i made a mistake
it's not my fault it literally wasn't me
no one saw it i was an electrical dual
environment
i was in electrical this feels good man
i missed playing minecraft
yo what the [ __ ] why did i build this
this is so
weird let's make sure i'm wearing the
light brush
all right easy easy
easy oh god oh god oh god oh god oh god
oh god okay okay
now where the arm are you though okay
here we go
jesus christ oh god
we're good we're good we're good i don't
know what he'll oh he dropped one
stop shooting me i'm sweetie i've said
it a million times
did we get any okay we got two i think
that's all i need
maybe one more yo he dropped one what
the [ __ ]
look i can wear it yes
i'm so lucky with the drops dude okay
here we go
don't hurt
wait i only need four anyway all right
i'm done i'm done i'm outside
i'm outside we need to find gas where my
gas where my gas where my gas stay
isn't there a biome with only gas in it
i feel like i saw that
that is way too cool you have to die now
hey go go
go that's the real reason i'm wearing
the mask so might someone hear me
so loud yo okay okay okay
okay oh he found it
all right all right you want to play
volleyball
oh god oh god never mind oh my god
come on yeah cheers
give me a tear back
how he's so far away dude
oh i got him no tears
oh oh here we go yes he dropped one
hell yeah all right nice cool the end
looks
totally different now it's like a brand
new game dude
but yeah if you have the ideas for me
things for me to do in minecraft let me
know
jesus christ not dying would be great
what did i do what i do what i do
they just come and attack you just
because i fresh pass on their lane
like i didn't want to kill their
younglings but now they have to
hey yeah i killed the younglings
so why
give me your tears your tears will
be mine there you are my love
mid-air mid-air flying
flying mid-air landing landing five
seconds later shoot
yeah see that fear me
hell yeah all right we got two this is
good just two more
they keep shooting each other
[Music]
yeah come on last one
we got it uh i'm done i don't need to do
this anymore
all right all right tricks about that
[Music]
oh
ah you see that on the king
home sweet home alabama it's a perfect
name
really it was meant for a different
purpose but it's the perfect name
of course i will pay my taxes out of
them of course
uh boom thank you stay safe alabama
remember where i'm at oh my god pp tower
gross every time i see it dude
i'm back then i made it i love you
yes we got the end crystals then
it's a really cool look here they look
lame here but if you put them down they
look really good
i think you have to put them down on uh
obsidian
yeah look at that sven that's so cool
hey
damn why do people not use those as
decor they look insane dude
dude hell yeah that looks insane
all right i like it i like it it's ben
stop bathing jesus
ben you're my best friend i love you
more than edgar
there's a reason why edgar cam isn't
here today because he's
useless he's pathetic i'm just kidding
anyway it feels good to be back in
minecraft
thank you guys so much for your support
as always
let me know what other stuff you want me
to see next episode we're going to kill
the ender dragon
now the moment you've all been waiting
for what's inside my man
well it's time for me to reveal
pewdiepie phone case skins
wow what is this get it out of here
i have designed these together with d
brand
yes that's right guys i am that
shameless i am so sorry
protect not just your face but also
your phone uh
so each one of these are different each
print of these
will look slightly different as you can
see we got
classic uh this one i'm super happy with
it's the floor gang 2020
to infinity that's right this meme never
dies
i'm really excited to be working with
dbrand they're a really good brand high
quality stuff
it's not just for iphone literally
almost any phone you have they have a
case for
i'm super proud of these check them out
every design is different and if you
want to be a little subtle look at this
one
yeah yeah you see that that's like
saying
yes i have a big peepee but no i don't
need to tell everyone about it that's
what that
case is called i think that's what we're
renaming it the mask is great if you
feel like you want to buy one
it looks cool what can i say so yeah
please go ahead check out dbrand.com
pewdiepie get yours today they even do
for nintendo switch
i was legit blown away when i saw this i
was like holy [ __ ] how did they even do
that
dude they do customs playstations and
all that stuff it's really dope
d brand high quality stuff legit excited
to be working with them
money shot that's it all right thanks
for watching guys
leave a like see you next time breakfast
wait barry is still level one courage
and you haven't fed bob god damn
sickness
get only 19 year olds because their new
trials mode
is like use your full pixeling roosters
to defeat as many enemy waves as
possible
download pixel links instantly for 20
muscle increase oh